Hey, this is hilarious.
We've not done anything like this for a while
because we haven't talked about Christian
televangelists.
Pat Robertson for a long time.
He still at it.
He's hosting his 700 club program.
He's 89 years old.
He still has that same cohost.
He still takes these audience questions where
you can't tell if they are parodies or serious
questions from people who don't realize that
it doesn't make any sense to go to Pat Robertson
for advice.
I was sent this clip yesterday where someone
said, David, you've got to see this.
Pat Robertson got a question from some guy
who claims that his wife wants to bring in
their Christian pastor as her extra lover.
She wants to swing or she wants an open relationship
or something with their pastor.
And the husband went to Pat Robertson asking,
what should I do?
So when I heard about this before even watching
the clip, I was wondering, is Pat Robertson
going to take it seriously or will he identify
it as a fake trolling question?
I don't know if it's a joke or if it's for
real.
But what I knew immediately was if Pat Robertson
takes it seriously, he is going to attribute
his wife's behavior, the E, the, the, the
viewers, wife's behavior, uh, to demons.
Because with Pat Robertson, everything is
demonic.
Over the last 10 years on this program, Pat
Robertson has called the following things,
demonic secondhand sweaters that you get at
Goodwill.
They could have demons attached to them from
the previous owner.
Weegee board's yoga, anything.
Harry Potter, Feng Shui, the, I guess it's
Japanese.
Um, a, a design interior design technique.
Um, Kara Tay, the martial art horoscopes,
the Twilight series, paintings of Buddha TV
shows about ghosts.
Halloween, obviously psychics, young girls
who levitate their friends at sleepovers,
definitely demonic.
And sometimes even children that you adopt
from other countries can come with demons
attached according to Pat Robertson.
So let's get right into the clip.
How does he handle it exactly as predicted?
This is Michael [inaudible] says to your pad.
I've been married to my wife for eight years
and we are very active in our local church.
Last week she shocked me when she said she
wants our pastor to be her quote, extra lover.
This does not make any sense since I give
her all the love and compassion that I can
give.
Our pastor does not know her plan.
Should I talk to him first before she tells
him, Oh, you'd better talk to somebody.
That is the weirdest psychological [inaudible]
six problem.
She is a been captured probably by some demonic
spirit Butler.
What's she saying?
She's married to you, has a successful marriage
with you.
You give her whatever she wants, but she wants
to quote the extra lover.
Where does she get the concept?
Yup.
There it is.
It's demonic possession for sure.
I love how he diagnosis demonic possession
in the same casual way that a plumber tells
you the flapper on your toilet needs to be
replaced.
It's like the exact same demeanor.
Oh yeah.
That's demonic possession.
That's what that is.
Then this is also funny.
Later in the clip, the cohost seems visibly
shocked that someone who's active in a Christian
Church could also be wanting to have sex with
her pastor outside of marriage.
Take a look.
[inaudible]
where does she get that concept?
That is absolutely wrong and she's active
in her local church, so she [inaudible] she's
being active in church really doesn't mean
anything much.
It just means you're active.
It doesn't mean necessarily, you know, you're,
you're given over to the Lord.
You need to talk to that pastor and you need
to alert him who, what's going on and then
you need to get that wife to some kind of
counseling and deliverance cause she, she's
been captured by something that sounds extremely
evil.
All right.
Pat Robertson actually correct here.
I mean, let's listen.
He's completely out of his mind, but he's
right.
Just being active in a Christian Church doesn't
make you anything and he could not be more
right about that one little thing of broken
clock, right?
I guess once every few decades.
In this case.
It sounds to me like the wife needs a good,
good old fashioned exorcism to solve this
problem.
So what do you think?
Is this fake or not?
I mean, on the one hand, who would even write
to Pat Robertson with a problem like this?
Like who?
Who thinks that Pat Robertson could solve
any problem but at the same time he's still
going, he's still on air.
So there must be some people that see Pat
Robertson as a purveyor of good sound advice,
which may be the scariest thing of all.
I want to hear from you.
Leave a reply, leave a comment if you're watching
on YouTube or send me a tweet at D Pacman
after following me.
Of course.
Do you think that this was a serious question
or is this just a satirical troll?
Speaking of satirical trolls,